Welcome to the town of Asbestos, Quebec.
These days, 'asbestos' is a word with
a sense of doom attached to it.
But when this mine was opened in the
late 19th century, that really wasn't the case.
Which is why they named the town after it.
This pit just here was the biggest
asbestos mine in the world.
Asbestos is a mineral,
easily mined in pits like this.
It can be turned into strong, cheap,
fire-resistant insulation,
and it was used in a huge number
of building projects in the 20th century.
Either as big insulation blocks, or in
ceiling tiles, or just sprayed on as cladding.
It was a miracle substance:
it could even be woven into clothing, like
military uniforms or firefighters' gloves.
The catch is that it's made up of
microscopic little fibrous crystals.
If you break asbestos, drop it,
sandpaper it,
turn it into insulation and spray it around,
those little fibres get into the air
and build up in people's lungs.
Decades later, people who've worked with absestos,
or lived near an asbestos mine,
they tend to develop a particularly nasty
type of cancer called mesothelioma.
Any exposure to asbestos fibres, however small,
can be dangerous.
And in this town, there was sometimes so much
asbestos dust in the air
that kids could write their names in it
when it settled.
We know all that now, so:
why haven't they changed the name?
In 2006, the town's then-mayor
tried to change it,
but the idea was voted down.
And I wanted to find out why, but no-one from
the town wanted to talk to me.
I emailed quite a few places, the local government,
the historical society.
Everyone either said no, they weren't interested,
or just didn't reply.
They were polite, of course, they're Canadian,
but it wasn't for them.
And it took me perhaps a little bit too long
to realise why.
The name attracts people like me
and viewers like you.
I knew this video was going to be titled
"A Town Called Asbestos" right away,
it's the obvious title,
it's got a ring to it.
Which is why there's already a five-part series
on YouTube from 2011 called exactly that,
put together by a researcher who spent years
with this town.
She turned her PhD into a book, also titled
"A Town Called Asbestos".
Vice.com published a series
by a German photojournalist,
titled "A Town Called Asbestos".
All the time, people turn up here, to document
The Town with The Name.
Some of them, like this author,
are thorough and sympathetic
and take decades of history into account.
Some aren't.
Some just set up a camera by the mine overlook,
turn up for a couple of hours and film something.
Others don't even visit, they just make fun
of them from the other side of the world.
"Why? Because the town's name is Asbestos."
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
How do you feel about the name?
Why don't you change it?
They've answered these same questions
for years,
and I suspect they're
very, very tired of it.
The clearest answer that I've found is from
an interview in the Globe and Mail in 2016.
Ghislain Tessier, vice-president of a local
chamber of commerce, said:
"Asbestos was our lives.
It was our heritage."
And I think that's the key to why this town
is still called Asbestos.
Because, yes, for most of the world,
the name is alarming.
But here, that's tempered with the fact that
this mine,
like a coal mine or a gold mine,
it was how people made their living.
Lots of people worked in the mine,
and their parents, and their grandparents,
and their great-grandparents.
It was part of their identity, a mineral that
the world wanted to use,
it was made right here by them,
and it saved lives,
and it really was something to be proud of.
Asbestos, and this mine, was defended by the
folks who worked here.
In '97, just after France banned asbestos,
four men from this town,
four of the luckier ones,
ran the Paris Marathon.
And they were congratulated in a statement
in Canada's Parliament
for showing that the risks weren't that great.
Because the risks were drastically downplayed
by management and by government.
Even after the world at large agreed
how dangerous asbestos is,
economics and the desire for profit meant
that it was still mined for decades here.
This mine only closed in 2012.
It's only been a few years.
Maybe the name will change,
if only to stop jerks like me coming along
and going, 'ooh, look at this place'.
But not just yet.
Dr Jessica van Horssen's book is the definitive
history of the town and the mine,
a lot of this video is based on it, and I
thoroughly recommend it.